the head of the motherly ngc uh wanted
to make a band
like a boy band like um uh
uh if you can google it by the way like
we were uh kind of
known throughout the lands of panama you
were in a [ __ ] boyfriend what the
[ __ ] is going on right now dude
and it was organized by the motherly
agency head right
and he just okay hold on
so you want to go you have to go be a
[ __ ] model right you go you take
their pictures they go listen
this is not gonna work in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the
genius brain podcast i'm your host david
so and today
on artist spotlight nice that's not a
section
so recently uh on this podcast i've been
you know kind of on the hunt
looking for new artists to kind of
highlight so
before you i had somebody named jason
cheney it was a super funny standard
comic that kind of came through here
and this is like a lot of people on the
space that i don't think people
know of as much as other people right
and i know this sounds a little weird
but for me personally i'm a very
spiteful human being so there's just a
lot of really
terrible people and not not towards like
personality but in terms of their talent
they really [ __ ] suck
and so my my my thing is like okay since
i have a platform i'm going to find new
people
and then bring them on this podcast and
kind of give them a lot of spotlight so
for you
i i found you through the most just just
igtv
i don't know i don't know who posted you
but somebody posted you doing
uh a version of willy wonka's your
imagination
true imagination on on the on the guitar
and you play
so if for people who don't know who this
is this is reuben
juan last name's one w-a-n okay ruben
one and
um yeah i found you through instagram
and it kind of blew me away i was like
who the [ __ ] is this guy right
and you look super [ __ ] young um so
welcome to the podcast i'm actually 56
[Laughter]
thank you very much for inviting me it's
super random i've been a fan since i was
like 17. oh that's correct i'm actually
26.
oh really yeah i'm just going to look 17
right now dude
that's [ __ ] random i've been in l.a
for eight years that's crazy but i
followed you since i was in panama
already
really like actually would i would sit
with all my cousins my sister
like six people would just watch uh
first like through jk news and would see
like the
the interactions there and then by
myself i'll just like
go through your youtube and search for
most popular and watch all the
uh kunyang hai and like the how [ __ ]
you know what's so random about this in
panama by the way this central america
yeah it's not like i'm in l.a like i
discovered youtube for a friend like
it's just i'm in this tiny little town
in panama
with all my asian cousins just watching
jk news and then by myself up just like
narrowed out on your stuff [ __ ] crate
that blows my mind yeah
because i forget that when we create
these videos it goes
outside of los angeles you know because
when we create these videos we're not
really
i'm i mean i think me and jk are are a
little different in the sense of
that we didn't i think we just created
just because we liked to yeah
right that wasn't an objective of
garnering millions and millions of views
it was just okay i think this is funny
and i want to do this
let me see if people enjoy it or if they
if they enjoy what we talk about
and it just it's kind of weird because
the person before here jason
he also watched me when he was uh
younger as well too yeah
and it's just very odd like because i
don't i don't think about
what happens when i create the video and
who it affects right yeah we just we
just kind of create stupid [ __ ] and we
talk about dumb stuff
and then we see what happens yeah how
[ __ ] insane even on a personal level
like
it's not like a 10-year gap like me with
you but
i get uh like with a five years gap
because i've been creating for the past
eight years since i've been in l.a right
yeah so i have fans that have been
following me for five or six years
and they come up to me and they start
singing a song that i wrote five six
years ago
wow like first of all how do you find
this random video i
did six years ago and two you actually
took your time to learn the lyrics and
learn the
actual melody to my song yeah and then
you have the balls
like the like the chord should come up
to me say hi
and then start singing it right away
yeah yeah yeah and i'm just like wow
thank you so much yeah how did you start
getting into music like into music
yeah specifically playing the guitar
specifically guitar
uh i've told this story a million times
uh
i was probably 15 years old so 10 years
ago
like around 10 years ago and i was
in high school at that time it was
probably i think me
between middle school and high school
right and i just wanted to pick up a
a new skill set yeah and i was very
bored summer vacations i tell my mom
mom uh there's this guitar course uh
my current high school like can i enroll
and like do this summer
course thingy she's like sure why not
and i'm like oh cool
and then she bought me my first acoustic
guitar and from there on i just
practice and practice i learned four
chords in three months it took me three
months to learn my first four courts
why the [ __ ] did it take you so long
because i only had one teacher in the
school right okay
and then i was like four quarters and he
was
a painter he was an art teacher that
knew a couple guitar
chords right yeah and the duration of a
chorus was three months right
and every single day he would be like
here's the four chords
and hear all these songs that you can
play with the four chords
and he would just tell me to shed those
and for some reason like
my 15 year old self i was so um in the
mord or just like
so passionate about just even though my
fingers hurt like crazy
i would just sit outside of the
classroom even after the class because
we only had like one hour class i would
stay there four hours
just trying to nail these four chords
for the whole two three months i was
there just nailing these four chords
and that's how i fell in love with the
guitar but the true reason
was to pick up girls of course how it
always did why the [ __ ] the [ __ ] else
would anybody pick up a [ __ ]
instrument
but the problem with that is i was
pretty i was way chunkier back then and
but it still [ __ ] works it always
works
and girls were impressed by the skill
but they weren't in love with it you
know yeah and that's how i should play
the guitar with your penis that'd be
different
that would have been really talented or
being a great skill to have
yeah so you so you picked up guitar when
you were 15. i mean yes
how'd you go from learning like three or
four chords to being as good as you are
now right just only because
when when i was younger everybody played
guitar like when you're korean you go to
a church yeah everybody [ __ ] yeah
you know but from playing like the few
christian chords to learning how to
understand and
i was actually uh uh uh how is
a worship leader back then of course you
were yeah and
that was the other angle you know like
when you're a worship leader you're
trying like
i just had a conversation with some
friends i just came back from seattle
and like washington area
and i met a group of people like uh
there were a couple church people too
and the stories everyone was sharing is
so international everybody had the same
exact story about
learning an instrument playing the
guitar to pick up girls at church
or like the church camp like you
purposely sit next to the girl you like
so like
when you stand up you can hold their
hands i've always said this a hundred
percent
and every time i have some [ __ ]
artists come on this podcast and i ask
them okay hey so why did you pick up
dancing or blob they go
okay when i first saw i'm like shut the
[ __ ] up what was the real reason and
that'll be always
to pick up a [ __ ] girl that's what it
is that's what it always is that's why i
picked the guitar that's why
i started singing was only because i
wanted women to talk to me and that's it
and then the art itself kind of like
brings you of course
but my first instrument was actually
piano like at 8 years old and
you know asian parents they're like oh
here's the piano
here's a classical piano t-shirt just go
at it
hated it like i did it for two three
years and
at some point i was so bored by it that
i just quit
and it took me three years to like
re-pick up a different instrument
yeah that's crazy so so you go from
picking up guitar
and obviously there's like this okay so
for people who don't know
you're you're not from the states i'm
not from you're from uh
you you were born and raised in panama
central america yes that's [ __ ] crazy
man yeah because i
i only actually know only maybe a couple
of people who are asian who
grew up in central america uh
specifically like brazil
uh there's like a huge korean community
out there which i have no [ __ ] idea
and japanese yeah which i i don't
understand where the
how that immigration happened there i'm
not sure about
brazil but for panama it was um
twofold the first one was the how do you
call that the train like the
they were building a train so they had
to get cheap labor from china
oh and the second one was the canal i
don't know if you've heard of the panama
canal yeah that's where
panama kind of connects north america
with south america
and we're right in between we have this
canal that like levels up the waters
from both oceans and they need cheap
labor as well so that's how we had an
influx of chinese people oh yeah okay
okay so
i i don't know the exact percentage of
people but there's probably
one out of 25 people is chinese probably
in panama
really yeah what the [ __ ] it's that big
of a community
my uh yeah it's because pam is small too
pam only has like
four or five million people and the
population of chinese people is probably
200 three hundred thousand so it's like
about
uh either seven to ten percent of
uh the population is checked wow it's
that small yeah
i might be butchering up the numbers but
mine was like
[ __ ] you there's a lot more than that
but my like my high school
classroom we were we only had like
10 asian like no sorry 10 non-asian
people like i graduated with a full
batch of chinese people
if you see my photos yeah what in the
[ __ ] my perception
of like panama is way different from how
you're describing it yeah i mean
there's it's pam is called the melting
pot of
uh latin america and we have like
colombian people
we have venezuelan people we have
everything right but chinese people is
very predominant out there
what in the [ __ ] world yeah so okay
so so what was it like growing up for
you there then so it wasn't
so you saw a lot of people who look like
you out there yeah and
the the funny thing is that out here
when i speak spanish
to like everyone like especially mexican
ladies or whatever
they are very surprised by it right but
growing or even knowing
because i can speak chinese too right
everybody's like very surprised at the
fact that i'm
i can speak multiple languages but for
me i was kind of
put in the situation where i grew up
like at home i had to speak chinese
the country forced me to speak spanish
and then my high school or my
school because i went to the same school
throughout my whole um
youth it was a british school so they
taught all the classes in english so
everything was kind of forced upon me so
i didn't actively learn a language so
it's not
as impressive as people like make it to
be
does that make sense because it's just
like a everyday life everyday life yeah
so
when you tell someone hey like uh well
you don't tell someone
people find out find out that you can
speak multiple languages or
wow so it's pretty impressive like you
have to go like
daily practice all these languages i
mean specifically in this country right
because
we're very singular here yeah most most
people in this country
only speak one language which is
american english right
everything else like i mean we're taught
secondary languages or tertiary
languages in
high school in high school whatever but
nobody really keeps it we only learn the
basics
our second language in my high school
was spanish actually
so the country forced me to speak
spanish but
my class as a second language was
spanish which was
it's super um interesting and weird at
the same time yeah but
um yeah that's just just i was forced
upon the three languages like
best songs yeah so it's not an
impressive thing i'm very
blessed and i'm glad that i was put into
a situation where
i had to know all three languages to
live in the like
my um upbringing so now it's an
advantage to my career or just like my
daily life
but it's not something that i had to
grind for i mean that [ __ ] works for you
really well here though specifically los
angeles right
yeah like learning how to speak spanish
here is is so useful and i i just
i'm inclined toward learning languages
too like maybe it's because of that like
i really like
japanese portuguese in korean like i
just
on my free time i like to just go over
words and learn vocabulary
from different languages is spanish in
panama different from
from here uh so here the most uh
spoken spanish is the mexican one which
is like
they have a specific like uh elato and
you know like that type of
vibe but spanish in paloma is very plain
so if you don't really go to like the
countryside or like the
uh outskirts of panama the language is
actually very very plain like it's the
most
uh no accent type of spanish that you
can find
it's just everyone can understand it
basically there's no strong accents or
anything about it
[Music]
hello my friends this podcast is brought
to you by ipvanish for those of you who
don't know
ipvanish is a vpn or virtual private
network that helps you safely browse the
internet
simply put if you are on your computer
doing just about anything
and you don't have a vpn by ipvanish are
you nuts being online is fun but your
data is everywhere and
having it encrypted is a must i'm not
just saying that you have to get
ipvanish because your online security is
super important
for browsing and keeping your personal
data and information encrypted i'm
saying it because you
have to do it here's everything you get
with ipvanish
anonymous ip address this means your
personal ip address can't be tracked by
anyone on the web
circumvent any online
censorship get protection when using
public wi-fi so basically nobody can
stoop on your data or see what you're
doing online
so go to ipvanish.com brainclaim your 65
savings they have plans starting at just
3.49 a month or 27.99 a year this is the
time to sign up
with our discount and their current
promotional offerings you can get a vpn
for 65
off their usual offering ipvanish is the
best of the best even rated 4.7 out of 5
on trust pilot
and that's with more than 6 000 reviews
show these guys some love remember it's
ipvanish.combrain
to get the deal and start protecting
yourself online today
you can make it like strong acts that
you can find the specific words that
let's say a different state or province
uses
to like accentuate different words but
if you speak
plain panamanian uh any
spanish-speaking country will understand
oh so you guys are kind of like the
prototype so
yeah i guess the prototype would be
spain yeah but
you know uh panama kind of has a very
plain spanish for some reason
the the the spanish like i met somebody
from spain but they're spanish
they have like a lisp or something yeah
so they go for example
yeah like that's the the spain yeah
spanish but
panamanian would be like hola como estas
yeah like it's very
uh i don't even know how to say like it
kind of reminds me of like
uh i guess like uh taiwanese mandarin
right so like yeah maybe it's very like
when i hear taiwanese mandarin i could
hear
different words it's very clean yeah i
mean versus when you hear
the the one from the mainland yeah yeah
yeah it's fair and even within mainland
china
every province have their own
intricacies and how they speak their own
mandarin yeah yeah like the north from
the south
and like yeah every place has like their
different dialects and way too oh yeah
100
yeah so for you so when when did you
move here and then what made you move
here in the first place
just because you know i mean for a lot
of people out there
i think when people come from a small
town usually people stay in their small
towns
yeah like it's a very scary i mean first
of all i mean you you just said that the
population of panama was what
four five million or five million people
and you go from four or five million to
a whole [ __ ]
like country yeah yeah california itself
is probably
more better than pound well four or five
i think la is bigger than that
yeah i think yeah exactly you know the
city of la is bigger than that it's
crazy
four or five billion is when i left so
yeah eight years there probably have
been like
more people yeah six million now yeah uh
what made me move out here was
i've always wanted to study abroad right
even when i was in
uh 9th grade 10th grade 11th grade like
my dream has always been to
move out of panama and explore the world
because i'm an internet baby right like
i just grew up with a computer stuck at
home playing my guitar playing video
games like that was me i was not
a very social person per se like i would
go out and stuff but
i spent most of my time at home in the
computer and looking at all the
interactions worldwide
made me really want to see the world
outside right
and i explored many options right like
when i was in 11th grade
like second to last year before
graduating i went to london to see some
schools
my dad recommended some schools in china
in taiwan i really i personally wanted
to go to japan to study
oh yeah but my mom was like no no no too
many earthquakes and natural disasters
you're not going there yeah i'm like
fine
um which was a good look because there
was a huge in between that time there
was a huge [ __ ] tsunami earthquake so
your mom was right just she was right um
but i still love japan i
really want to go to japan someday and i
landed on la so
before i came to la i worked at kpmg i'm
not sure if you know
so between my graduating
year and my year in la i had like a gap
year right you know how everybody takes
like a gap year between high school and
university right and i took a gap year
and for me
my gap year was first i did an
accounting job i hated it
i did it for three hours i did it for
three months what the [ __ ] would you go
and do accounting man
i was put into it because uh how my high
school worked is uh the last three years
they give you a
emphasis right like they give you a very
specialized curriculum
you can choose between being like the
science guys like biology
physics chemistry you can choose the
business route which is the one i took
which is accounting economics
and like business classes and there's
the third route the art
one like you learn arts you learn music
and stuff like that
and asian parents i went told you to go
to business route
and once you graduate like the top
few students get a chance to intern at
the top
accounting firms in panama or worldwide
there's like four big accounting firms
like kpmg
uh ernest and young deloitte and stuff
like that right and i got the chance to
interact kpmg
i got offered a job did it for a couple
months hated it
like that's what made me realize i'm not
suited for the corporate life right
yeah so right after that i joined a
modeling agency
it's it's where my it's very weird hold
on
what the [ __ ] do you mean you joined a
[ __ ] modeling agency
how [ __ ] random it's very random it's
very made you go into a model
okay this is your timeline is all [ __ ]
up
graduation 18 right yeah first
graduate did you go okay i'm gonna be a
[ __ ] accountant which clearly wasn't
gonna work out for you
you know and then you go okay you know
what [ __ ] this i'm a model
you just go from that to that how the
[ __ ] did that happen
i think i think i have i had a couple of
friends
that were doing it right yeah yeah yeah
and there's different type of models
there's the
uh i don't know how you call the runway
ones yeah like in spanish it's called
pasarella
and there's the the models that go to
like conventions right
and they give out flyers they're like
standing at uh different boots and stuff
like that
and i'm like why not like let's get a a
part-time job
like doing modeling gigs right funny
enough i never landed a modeling gig
but i did the photo shoot and everything
to get like the portfolio
okay but through the modeling agency um
by the way the modeling agency was
wilhemina i don't know if you've heard
of it
willamina but the panama franchise the
head of the modernly agency
uh wanted to make a band like a boy band
like uh
uh uh if you can google it by the way
like we were uh
kind of known throughout the lands of
panama you were in a [ __ ] boy band
what the [ __ ] is going on right now dude
and it was organized by the motherly
agency head right
and he just [ __ ] hold on
so you want to go you have to go be a
[ __ ] model right you go and you take
the pictures they go listen this is not
going to work out but
it's not very interesting here yeah
you're going to get more surprised in
the middle
like hold on a second you're not you're
not a model dude but we have this little
boy there that i want you to be a part
of
do they know that you could play the
guitar yes they did how the [ __ ]
random
yeah and they they really went through
their
portfolio of models and picked up people
that knew instruments right they found a
drummer somehow
they found a couple singers so i was a
back uh
backup background vocals yeah like
second vocals or whatever
but i was a lead guitarist right so they
wanted everyone to resem
uh resemble the beatles so the head of
the modeling agency was a fan of the 50
60s and 70s music right so he wanted a
cover boy band that did beatles elvis
presley
like all this is like retro music so the
band was called
rhett like based on retro music right so
he picked a bunch of
models that played instruments he put it
together
and all of our shows were for rich white
people
in panama yeah so they paid really well
they treated us
really well we had like uh makeup
artists and hair stylist and we had like
writers and everything so that was my
first taste
of what a successful music career could
look
like right yeah and that's when i fell
in love with the attention and stuff
like that
i was in the band for probably six seven
months
and i thought there was a ceiling you
know like pam is such a small country
like i don't want to be doing this
boyband thing forever
like um i really love music i want to
take it somewhere else
and that's when i um try to look into
schools music schools right
and the easiest music school to get into
was one here in la
and that's the one i applied for i got
accepted and i decided to move my whole
life to l.a like after getting accepted
what the [ __ ] that's crazy so six to
seven months playing this
bad thing this boy band yeah and during
magazine covers and everything like if
you google it real quick like you're
coming
i gotta see [ __ ] photos i gotta see
performances and this is all
and you guys are all singing in spanish
by the way no in english so we would
sing like twist and shout and like all
those like uh
old school songs i want to hold your
hand and stuff like beetle song
and we wear suits in every single part
oh they really wanted you to be like the
beatles yes crazy yes yes yes and
like they wanted a specific look it's
like
it's a head of a modeling agency this
was his this was probably his childhood
dream right 100
this was his childhood and he forced it
yeah yeah and we're
we're all like it's paying well like
there's an audience and we're still
doing
music you know and that was our modeling
gig slash
uh cover boy band thing right nowadays
they even do
choreography and stuff but me as the
first generation we didn't do
like yeah choreography or anything like
we were just playing
straight up covers like maybe like uh
changing it up a little bit
and yeah if you google them nowadays
they dance and everything
so [ __ ] so the boy band
you left i left first i was i was
probably the first one to leave the boy
band okay yeah and then
the uh did is it just so do they have
the same band but they just flip people
everybody start leaving because
the first generation of rhett reads is
the band's name
with a z at the end uh the first
generation we were all more serious
musicians right
not that the current ones are not
serious musicians right but we wanted
different things like we played rock we
played fusion music we played ladding
uh salsa and whatever so everybody
wanted to explore
different music worlds right and same
with me i didn't want to be stuck doing
cover boy band songs for the rest of my
life right so i realized at first
i left and slowly everybody also left
and they had to
replace the members one by one right and
what was their
original method they went through the
models list and like
they looked at it and they got to a
point where
i think they realized that the band
thing didn't work like the music band
thing didn't work
so i think the i haven't checked them in
well but the most
current lineup is all really handsome
looking like
young guys that's is it like the the
k-pop model type of thing right
without the full-on like yeah dancing
and stuff
and the music is still very chill
compared to like all the edms
okay okay okay yeah so it's not like the
k-pop model
but it's still like the boy band model
where they have like uh
a bunch of pretty handsome boys like
doing choreography while singing songs
that girls love
yeah how did it feel for you when you
started doing music because obviously
you went the accounting around the
modern wrath in the music route
number one did it feel right and number
two like did you enjoy
all the attention like what was that
what was the feelings i've
i've never regretted anything i've done
in my career
except like in la a couple things but uh
back then
i think everything led me to here right
yeah so i'm very grateful for every
single experience
and i'm kind of omitting like uh now
that you mentioned the k-pop thing i
also did k-pop competitions in panama
of course okay
what the [ __ ] okay you gotta explain to
people what the [ __ ] a k-pop competition
yeah
so that's crazy first of all like this
is what i talk about when i say
how weird it is and how how influential
korean pop music is yes right because
when i was when i was younger
in uh high school and stuff right i
liked korean pop music but i never
shared that with people afraid to get my
ass beat
you know i mean like you you share with
people that you like k-pop music with a
bunch of dudes that look like women
oh you even like when i was young like
you wouldn't share this yeah you would
you wouldn't share it right but i had a
couple like close friends were like
oh like here the wonder girls like and
they're like what are the wonder girls
but it's like your best friends are like
oh check this this is the wonder girls
and then slowly you turn them into like
oh
like i like this member too i like that
i mean you could only imagine right
because you and i were like seven years
apart
right so from that seven being seven
years apart
but watching men wear makeup
is not something you would get your
[ __ ] ass because i grew up right like
you wear makeup people call you like a
[ __ ] a loser you know these are these
are the terms they used back in the day
not that i use
they call you like you know gay whatever
and they beat your ass they make fun of
you they do everything you can
so now it's like when i when i see the
identity of what a male can be wearing
makeup and doing all this other stuff
very androgynous yeah it's very
androgynous now and people are just kind
of like yeah
that's cool so when i see that reach
over to like you know south america
right which from what i've heard from
people it's very like machismo
i could only imagine yeah you probably
have to hide that you know
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
this podcast is brought to you by raycon
my friends
if you know me you know that i only
listen to my audio such as my podcast
with raycon earbuds whether you are
jogging
whether you are cooking whether you just
need a lightweight wireless earbud
to do your daily tasks raycon has the
answer for you
whenever i'm cooking in the kitchen for
hours i don't need nothing else besides
my knife skills and my rakons
to get me through standing on my feet
all day cooking in the kitchen on top of
that when i kick box when i'm hitting
the bag
i definitely always use my raycon
earbuds yes my friends
we don't play here at raycon they're
comfortable they're super lightweight
and they're not bulky so you can walk
around and do your thing
all super light and ethereal if as mike
tyson said i like to be super ethereal
with my earbuds
mike tyson here talking about the raycon
earbuds i've never punched somebody in
the mouth so hard
and still had earbuds sticking my ear
like these raycon earbuds it's amazing
it's ethereal i love it
so listen up mike is telling you guys
right now that raycon's offering
15 off all their products for my
listeners
and here's what you got to do to get it
go to buy recon dot com slash brain
there you'll get 15 off your entire
recon order and it's such a good deal
you'll want to grab a pair and a spare
that's 15 percent off at buy recon dot
com slash brain that's by recon
dot com slash brain but here's the thing
um it just depends on what crowds you're
hanging
out with because of course the machismo
thing is like very predominant
especially in latin american countries
but young people they just follow trends
and if you just hang out with the people
that are following the same trend
then you'll never face uh well you just
gotta find the right group you just have
to find the right group right
okay but i was talking about how the boy
band gave me my first taste of attention
but the real um taste of stardom
was through k-pop competitions actually
so
uh i did my first ever k-pop competition
when i was 18 like during that gap year
and i did a cover of i don't know like
big bang right like the oh [ __ ] the boy
and i used their most popular song back
then it was like haruharu like day by
day
and i was super nervous i'm like what
the heck am i doing like i'm gonna sing
a korean song in front of a bunch of
uh people i don't know right uh but i
wore my little suit like you know a
little suit and
back then the v-neck shirts were popular
and i had my
justin bieber emo cut going on too right
so that was popular within the k-pop
world
and the competition was dance covers and
a couple of singing people
i was the only person to play it with a
guitar and sing like a cover
and i did it uh slowly throughout the
progression of the cover
people realized what song it was and
they got louder and louder and they just
like start
cheering the song and just like singing
along 800 k-pop fans in a latin american
country right
500 to 800 i forgot the actual number
and once i was done i was like
wow like people can interact with
someone on the stage
at this level even though it's just a
random
korean song right i really want more of
this i really wanted the attention of
people cheering and just like
singing along to whatever i'm doing on
stage and
luckily enough i won the kpop
competition right after
i got like a flock of like people coming
mostly girls they want to like take a
picture and like they were just like
chasing me around i'm like
this feels nice and then my best friends
they were like oh yeah no more pictures
you know like at 18 years old like you
love the tension your friends are like
helping you and everything yeah yeah and
then i walked back to the car
and there were still people chasing i'm
like wow this is amazing
let's do this some other day right but i
just i'm really loving this attention
i go back home i wake up the next day
panamanian k-pop fans
made me a fan club like i woke up and
there was a facebook
reuben one fan club i'm like wow what
the heck is this how random it was super
random but it was enough
to like spark that um that drive
that drive and that hunger and thirst i
think it's there's
um it fed into my narcissism and my
pride and everything that an artist
needs
and that was enough to motivate me to
continue pursuing music for the rest of
my life and that's very important too
right
and i always talk to people about this
it's like and you kind of hit the nail
on the head
yeah when people ask what's what's
important to become like a performing
artist right
there is a lot of like narcissism and
ego yeah like you you have to actually
have this
and that was like one of the hardest
things for me right it's because
i didn't have much of that yeah and so
when
when people ask you there's a big
difference when i see myself and other
artists right
and they i look at artists and the
reason why they're so successful
is because they do enjoy the spotlight
yeah and i'm not saying this in a
negative way
like you have to enjoy the intention you
have to because that is going to be a
huge part of your life
i think the hardest struggle for me was
like i never lacked attention i just did
what i did
and it led to something else right and i
for some reason in my ignorance i always
thought that i could just do what i
wanted to do and have nobody notice me
yeah but that doesn't work that way like
you can't make a living off that here's
how stupid i was i was like i'm gonna be
like one of the biggest standard comics
but i want to still live in my hometown
of sacramento
how the [ __ ] is that going to work out
yeah it doesn't work that way how are
you going to sell shows with 10 people
in there
exactly it's not going to work out that
way so i've always had this weird thing
where it's just like okay
i'm becoming progressively more and more
known doing this stuff but i didn't want
people to know me
which didn't make any [ __ ] yes you
know so and the people that are the most
successful on the space are people who
enjoy and thrive off of other people's
energy
and attention um like for ie for an
example like there's the logan paul's
and the jake pauls
there's a reason why they do really well
on the space right it's not because of
sheer talent it's not because they offer
anything very unique
it's because they know and they thrive
off of people's attention
and this is what their model is based
off of right yeah and if you want to be
a great artist
you know i'm not not great artist if you
want to be an artist like
in entertainment there there has to be a
certain level of wanting to be in the
spotlight
if not it's not going to work out for
you you know because it's hard to deal
with yeah yeah
and i always say the people that can do
art without
craving the tension are the true artists
like per se
because they can do it just for the sake
of art for sure pushing
the limits of the of the genre or like
whatever category they're doing right
and i ha i crave a little bit the
pushing the boundaries of like the
instrument or like the art
but i feel like my thirst is more
towards um connecting with people right
having a connection uh yeah that's the
part of entertainment yeah that's the
yeah you're you're an entertainer yeah
i'm an entertainer more than the
boundary pusher right and you have to
realize what type you are right you
cannot be in between
because once you're in between you're
gonna you love too much your art you get
too hurt when people don't like it
or at the same time you make art that
you don't like but people love it and
you hate yourself for making art you
don't love what people love 100
and so it's really hard to be in between
like i want to be entertainer but also i
want to push the limits
it's hard to be there choose your lane
and know
what path you want to take as an artist
or it's performing that's the best way
because there's there's no other way
right there's you you have to figure out
what you're going to be yeah there's
i know there's somebody i know right now
like this dude
creates stuff only because he knows that
it's going to get him money and that's
where he lives yeah but when we have
side conversations about what he does he
[ __ ] hates it
every day he hates it he goes i've spent
most of my life trying to make money do
all this other stuff
and now all this is all i know yeah and
then he looks at what i have where i'm
not as rich as he is
but he goes i wish i would have done
what you did like you have long lasting
friendships connections
you're happy with everything that you
put out it's like well you got to pick
and choose your battles yeah
if you want to make shitty [ __ ]
content and make money that's okay
like just but you don't complain about
it like you chose it
there is a small percentage of people
that can do what they love and also make
the money part
yeah but that's rare like it's very i do
think it's pretty rare yeah it's very
super [ __ ] rare you know what i mean
and it's it's a lot harder i think
it depends on what what you can sleep
with right like i've i chose to do
podcasts i did food or whatever
this is not in the realm of like making
the most money possible it's something
that i very very much enjoy do the
things you enjoy
and that's what keeps me going there's
the only reason i could do this for
[ __ ] 12 years is because i
did what i enjoyed you know i i don't
have any regrets like i have like
okay you could have done this and you
could have been a lot bigger
who the [ __ ] cares i wouldn't have been
happy if happiness is your end goal you
just got to figure out what that [ __ ]
lane is do you have aspirations to be
bigger though
no this is this is to be honest you like
the platform growing is
is just the platform growing i had a i
had a conversation with a buddy of mine
and this dude was trying so hard to
reach a million subscribers on youtube
and he's been on youtube for a very
[ __ ] long time and when he hit
youtube like this dude started crying he
hit that million he started crying right
he was like oh my god i finally hit a
million it felt like
he achieved his life goal i think i know
right but then when he asked me he goes
hey
like dude it's like you remember when
you hit a million i go no
i don't remember that i once once my i
should you [ __ ] not
once i hit 300 000 it didn't [ __ ]
matter yeah
i was like oh i can do this and that's
all that [ __ ] mattered so his
perspective
of what you know these life goals and
these tickers like
i've already achieved more than i
thought i could people have to
understand like i grew up with
absolutely nothing
not nothing i had a good family and all
this stuff but in terms of like monetary
wealth and everything else and like i
told you
being famous was never an objective of
mine it was just to create stuff that i
really [ __ ] enjoyed
like being the best stand-up comic
wasn't because i wanted people to
watch me do what i do because i wanted
to make people laugh
the objective was very different so
whether i became
so everything that i have now is is a
bonus so you don't really hear me
complain about my life ever
i never complain about my life you know
why it's because i had an objective
my life goal was to be married have kids
and have a white picket fence house and
that was the height of my goals
well i've surpassed that times a million
so everything else is just about a bonus
a plus yeah everything is a bonus and a
plus right now even having you on this
platform right now
i'm not doing i'm doing it just because
i want i saw your videos and i'm like oh
i want people to know who he is
so thank you like so the objective of my
life is very different right and because
of that
when people ask oh what's your next
biggest step and my manager gets
frustrated too he goes what's your next
biggest move i mean i don't [ __ ] know
i don't know what the next biggest move
is like i didn't expect to go have a
netflix show sell this food show i
didn't expect any of this stuff
i just did what i did and it opened
doors for me so i like i don't suggest
people to live this lifestyle because
it's actually very chaotic
it's it's it's kind of stressful because
because i don't have set goals like i
used to when i was younger
and i'm just living and i'm surviving
like it's it's
it's it's very stressful
you know like if you don't have a
specific goal and you're not working
towards things i don't suggest people
who start out in the space to do that
i just i've developed enough uh projects
and i've developed
and i put enough time into it where i
can do that now so
if you ask me like what's my next big
goals i don't really [ __ ] know
it's okay yeah i think it's more
important that you're in a happy place
yeah than searching for the next big
thing yeah and this is what i tell a lot
of people even myself i need to wake
myself up every time
is uh the fact that people don't enjoy
when they reach certain milestones right
they reach one milestone and they're
right away they're looking for the next
thing to do
yeah and they don't actually rejoice in
the current situation they're
blessed with right like oh i achieved
this now
let me enjoy it let's go out with some
people and enjoy it together
celebrate the achievement and actually
live your life a little bit
and then look for the next thing like if
you're always searching for that next
thing
you're going to burn yourself out really
really fast 100
because like you people even ask like yo
where's your million dollar where's your
million subscriber plaque yeah i think i
threw it away when i moved
i don't know where it's at i completely
lost it yeah
like the silver one too i lost that too
like these these
physical or even like these number these
tickers they don't
give a value to my life they don't show
value at all yeah the proof is in the
pudding it's already there like i don't
need the [ __ ] plaque and if i want
that plaque i'll go
trophy shopping to make it for me again
like and even i'm gonna get a little
businessy yeah like
there's so many people with millions of
followers and subscribers
that are leaving dirt poor you know yeah
like the number one determine your
lifestyle the number is literally
just a number yeah like knowing how to
monetize uh whatever following you have
is ten times more important
than getting a huge number and just like
showing it off right
the flex culture in la specifically is
so predominant that is kind of
toxic at the same time like find your
niche
enjoy that community and grow together
with that community is ten times more
important than
trying to push for that one million one
million mark
what's the difference between 999.999
versus one million there's no difference
it's just
a number that shows up on the screen
yeah that's that's the hard part too for
a lot of young creators they they don't
understand the concept of like
it's not about the million that you have
in the fall it's about the connection
that you have with the few that follow
you
yeah because there's a lot of people out
there that'll die for you right yeah but
then if you're still reaching out to
this community
that number one they wouldn't care about
any new projects that come out they
don't share your stuff
they don't buy your merch like this
these people are the ones that matter
the most and when you focused on the
million instead of the hardcore
thousands it doesn't really [ __ ] yeah
you know um and and that's what a lot of
people get caught up in and for you too
you you're you're going from a very
small city to one of the most like
craziest cities in the united states
right there's a few metropolitan cities
that are considered
quite hectic san francisco los angeles
and new york
right i mean how was that adjustment for
you moving to los angeles from this
small town
because los angeles even for me i came
from sacramento which is a smaller town
yeah los angeles was a very very
difficult experience for me to kind of
acclimate to yeah i mean
till this day la is a love and hate
relationship yeah
uh trafficking yes i mean outside of
those things just like
finding real connections is really hard
yeah luckily enough after eight years
i do have a very close circle of
tight-knit friends
i'm really really uh
i really like to put importance on who i
call a friend
because especially in la at the
beginning everybody was a friend right
because that's how it happened in small
towns you have a mini talk
and then he's your friend and you guys
are friends for 10 years and it's all
cool to go to
school together yeah everything yeah in
la having a good
chat for 30 minutes people will start
calling your friend but it's
really hard to determine if that's a
true friendship or not it takes
a couple years to really know what's
this relationship about right
and not only that um compared to pama la
is already a very fast-paced
place even though compared to new york
it's still very yeah
uh so getting used to everybody grinding
every time like every time you're asking
somebody
the next big thing everybody's looking
for that next big job or i'm doing this
i'm doing that
they're trying to tell everyone what
they're doing and they're trying to
network and stuff like that
it happens in panama right but not at
such an aggressive rate
here as soon as i land it everybody's
trying to know
uh what you do how can i help you how
can you help me
and how can we do something together to
where do you live further occur
yeah yeah uh so that took me a little
time but i kind of expected it already
right i knew that i was gonna have to
do the network culture and stuff like
that and luckily for me
uh growing up i did have a lot of
chances to travel right
i've been to china many times i've been
to the states multiple times as well
before actually moving my whole life to
la i've been to la probably two three
times
because la is actually the place where
you have to transit to go to china oh
okay okay yeah so i would stay in l.a
for two three days so i i
i knew what the city looked like i just
didn't know what the culture of the city
was like right so that probably took me
a year two years to
get used to and we can go back to the
regrets thing right
because i was from a small town my first
two years in la actually didn't
like pursue like my passion as
as as much as possible right i was
enjoying the party lifestyle
i was like oh like la there's a party
every single day
every there's something to do every
single night so i was
um entangled with that uh lifestyle i
guess
so my first two years were kind of a
blur like i was just trying to go to as
many parties as i could
meet as many people as i could and just
live the life that panama didn't offer
but of course like panama also had that
thing i just didn't
like um it's different it's different
you have a new identity here in your
life yeah but then after those two years
it was out of my system and that's when
i started realizing
the people that were actually making it
in the industry right like what type of
grind
they had to do or like what the level of
artistry i need to
aim for and that's when i went back to
the
like my bedroom and just start shedding
like shedding the instrument
like shedding the art and just trying to
improve myself every single day
it took me two years to eliminate all
those
uh uh party lust i guess i can call it
like the
lifestyle i mean there's no regrets in
that too because you don't you don't
know what you miss out on until you do
it exactly and it took me that to
realize that
uh i needed to hustle and grind right
yeah
and i i guess it's not a regret but more
like
i could have used that time more wisely
but
la's la like i love it and i hate it i
guess yeah yeah yeah i mean it's a
it's weird right because like i you know
i've mentioned this on the podcast
before of
when people come to this city there's
you know i read these
tweets or like comments or even from
people who are outside from the city
because i've lived here what 11 years 12
years now or whatever
um people go oh you know everybody here
they're they're only here to network and
blah blah blah it's like well so are you
you know that's like so what did you
expect you know people
are going to give and take the same way
that you do you know
it's about understanding what the
relationship's about you know
you know coming from a very small town
you know obviously my town was
probably similar to yours but just in
different countries right it's just yeah
when you know the same people growing up
i had the same friends since i was in
elementary school in high school
so you know you keep people for life
yeah over here it's a little different
one of the biggest things that i hated
was like when people would call me their
brother or their friend and i'm like i
don't [ __ ] know you like that
don't call me your brother your friend
yeah but it's so easy here right they go
oh it's like oh yeah he's the homie i'm
not your [ __ ] i don't know you like
that bro
like i met you [ __ ] once you know
yeah and they throw these words out a
lot
and a lot of the times and we call this
like [ __ ] on the first date a lot of
people hear [ __ ] on their first date
and they say it so [ __ ] easy and
people get disappointed when people that
they just met stab them in the back it's
like
well you just met them you didn't
[ __ ] know them it's actually your
fault because you started calling them
brother
friend and best friend yeah the people
who do it the most in the city
girls yeah they love that [ __ ] bestie yo
oh my god i [ __ ] with this [ __ ] so hard
like she's so she's just like
and then two lee slayer she's [ __ ]
her uh her [ __ ] boyfriend yeah
how the [ __ ] did that happen is because
you don't [ __ ] know them you [ __ ]
on the first date
you don't know these people yet and the
the hardest part for people to do
is because the city is so exciting and
things move so fast yes is learning how
to separate
friends homies and acquaintances right
it's okay to say that that person is an
acquaintance it doesn't mean that you
dislike them or hate them it just means
you don't [ __ ] know them yes i have a
lot of acquaintances i have
a good amount of homies but i have a
very small amount of friends
and that's okay like you have to be okay
with that people look at relationships
and like these deep connections
as if you're supposed to have them in
abundance you don't look at look at
probably your parents my parents all
these older people they only hang out
with a few people
and my friends don't even have i don't
think they even have friends i think my
mom has one friend
yeah exactly because she's a [ __ ] he
has like one [ __ ] friend
that's really about it yeah and it's
especially hard for that generation like
my parents generation was such a
hustle and grind environment they could
care less about
like uh having friends everything is
just an acquaintance so
i can somehow survive this country
basically yeah
i mean you came here and uh so when you
came here you already knew how to speak
english and everything yes yes
so my parents didn't speak spanish when
they went to panama so
like those are my true superheroes and
idols i look up to like my parents those
are like
i don't even know how they did it but
they somehow managed
to uh build their own legacy in a
foreign country
and yeah i look up to that i get scared
i'm pressured because i might never
amount to the same level of success as
them
but it's at the same time very inspiring
to look at them and how they build their
lives
yeah so how did you go from you know the
parting life and then you decide to
grind out to
you know people knowing your music here
aside from your boy band stuff like how
do
people get to know your music here yeah
so after i did the k-pop stuff right i
kind of wanted to detach myself a little
bit from that because i got into the
i'm a musician yeah i'm an artist you
know uh
so eventually the fan club died and
stuff like that
i came to l.a party i was partying but i
was also going to music college at the
same time of course
yeah um my asian site didn't allow me
to fully fully party so i was still
trying to like excel at school
but at night she was like go have fun
and stuff but at the two years mark
that's when i
uh realized how talented all the people
around me were
i'm like oh i've had access to all this
um
what's the right word um people in the
same industry as you the colleagues like
yeah i had so much
access to all these talented colleagues
why don't i
like uh start um absorbing all the
knowledge i can right
and that's when i started grinding the
instrument i got okay
i got proficient like i could survive uh
the la
music scene because it gets a bit of a
it's like a dick measuring contest like
every time you go jam with like
session musicians and stuff like that uh
but i got to a certain level where i
could
i could hang with people right uh
i start going to jam sessions meeting
all the industry people i start doing
the session stuff as well
like i would do sessions and touring
with um
like famous artists like just uh behind
the scenes not me on the spotlight and i
thought that was
gonna be the rest of my career i thought
i had completely detached myself from
the spotlight
and i was more of like the background
people like helping
the artists become a bigger product uh i
did that for two more years so two years
of partying two years of
doing the session thing and then i
realized i actually won the spotlight
like i
started uh realizing that uh my pride
and my narcissism thing is bigger than i
thought it was
so i started craving the spotlight again
so i started doing my own stuff i
started releasing
fun little instagram videos where
instead of just jamming my
college practice exercises i would put
some more thought like outside the
camera
properly the lights and stuff like that
come up with a small
i think back then was 15 seconds 15
seconds instagram
15 second instagram composition right it
was probably
the stupidest thing ever on the guitar
but i put some effort into the video
and people liked it so my first well
produced video
uh received good attention i got my
first 1000 followers this was in like
2015 or 2014
yeah and to me that was that was it
right i'm like wow i have a thousand
followers that
liked uh this video and
that was enough for me to continue
putting out like little compositions
right guitar compositions
or singing or rapping and stuff and i
just did that consistently throughout
the rest of my college life
and that slowly snowballed into uh my
current following
and through it i've had multiple
opportunities here and there so i just
take them
when it comes like magazine like
interviews or uh
different like this like for this right
you discovered me because i put out a
video
on uh the internet and you liked it and
then you reached out and then we just
talked a bit and then this happened
right
so i've had a lot of those small
opportunities here and there
that kind of bundle into my current
career yeah
yeah so for you when you when you when
you so like you said you were busy all
throughout may this is like stuff that
you're doing
uh individually at shows or are you part
of a band ensemble like what
what are you books for uh so recently
i decided that everything i do musically
has to be kind of
a legacy it has to be like a legacy move
or something that is like
me right but may i don't know what
happened to may but i just started
accepting
all these like uh partnerships like with
different brands and like i started
doing
a bunch of um ads i guess that's how you
call like brand deals like for social
media and my youtube and stuff like that
uh i did a festival like
pre-recorded festival like a friend of
mine she's a singer and she really
needed a
guitarist so i did that as well we did
like a two three day rehearsal and then
like a
festival recording that will come out a
couple months later
i did a couple performances uh
me myself it was api month right asian
pacific
islander heritage month so i got a lot
of offers related to that
like there was uh like an award show
like online award show and they needed a
performance so i did a performance for
them
um instagram facebook or instagram they
were together they had like an event
where they were celebrating
uh asian american people so they asked
me to talk and i was part of their
panel and like a lot of things just
snowballed into may
like i thought may was gonna be all
about me writing songs for my upcoming
album
but no mate was all about brand deals
and just like talking at events
playing at events and doing like live
show performances and stuff like that
yeah do you have um do you have any
artists that you really want to work
with
like in terms of like playing for or
playing for
so i i decided that i don't want to play
for anyone anymore
because i already did like a couple
years of that already uh
but if i had the chance to i would do it
i would happily do it for haley williams
paramore i don't know oh yeah yeah yeah
so that would be like one of the
that's random yeah that's very random
that's very [ __ ] rad
why paramore because she's such an
amazing performer
i would not mind at all like being
behind the scenes just playing guitar
for such an uh
amazing performer i guess yeah yeah yeah
but to personally work with i have
a million people i would like gladly
work with
yeah yeah yeah yeah because like i i
work with you do you want to release the
song
okay i'm too busy doing [ __ ] right
now music is such a hard thing right
like i've i've never really enjoyed
music to where
i wanted to like pursue it it was always
just a side hobby right
like guitar was something i tried to
pick up because i wanted the same but
usually somebody else played for me
because i couldn't pick it up it was so
[ __ ] hard like i just
i couldn't do both it's so damn
difficult like even like playing the
guitar like i've
because i've never really tried to learn
the guitar per se
i never understood the instrument yeah
right because we were we were like
praise leaders players only knew their
very specific chords
we knew what to play we had the shitty
ass [ __ ] drummer shitty ass
and we just played praise music you know
yeah so in terms of like understanding
the instrument it was just something
that was like far out of my reach
when i see people play the guitar right
and i just i'm like i definitely don't
know the instrument
yeah like the instrument is a lot more
complicated than it actually looks
yeah because anybody can pick it up and
play their few chords
that's not a problem they could do the
same like rhythm strum that everybody
else does but learning how to play it
is something that blew my mind even like
somebody like aj raphael like when he
like
uh she reads oh he's amazing i'm like
what the [ __ ] how do you do that yeah
he's like oh well today like i just
found this sheet music that my
you know uncle had before and i'm just
gonna play it right now i'm like this is
the first time you ever saw it you sheet
right
like i don't get that [ __ ] yeah i guess
this is like improv like
yeah like when you do comedy and you
improv and you like riff with other
comedians it's the same skill
like you have to practice it and
eventually it becomes part of your skill
set and it just comes naturally
yeah i mean it's it's yeah like i when i
see
like i have a bunny name he's ken
belcher right he i think he went to usc
for
music or some [ __ ] right and he used to
right on i'm also a usc grad that's
awesome dude
like for him like he uh used to do
i was like hey i want to do this cover
and he was like oh cool let me listen to
it he goes got it and then
20 minutes later he records and he sends
it out to me i'm like yeah what the [ __ ]
guy
how the [ __ ] did you do that [ __ ] you
know like i don't understand it like
i don't understand how somebody can
listen to something and be like oh it's
this chord is this progression and is
this this isn't that yeah you know
it's so weird uh hear me out so there's
this example i
really love to bring up music is like a
language right everybody always say
music is a language
but the problem with um how people are
taught music
they don't teach music as a language
what they do is that
when you're eight years old they sit you
down and they tell you you are a
beginner
you are level one so here learn your
skills and like learn this is do remy
faso latido whatever right
if you really wanted to teach music as a
language right
little kids that are three years old um
they hear how adults are speaking and
they're learning how to speak the
language that's why at five years old
uh a five-year-old kid can speak english
like fluently right
if you really taught music that way like
just putting them in a situation
where they have to like survive if you
put a
three-year-old with a guitar right now
and we're two professionals jamming
he'll have to survive and adapt he'll
like learn what we're doing
okay and then he'll slowly start doing
it without knowing the alphabet or like
the words or whatever right
and eventually after a year of just
looking at professionals doing their
thing he will pick it up too that's how
little kids learn language
you put a three-year-old here hear a
speak for a whole year
he'll start speaking english fluently as
well right so it's not about the 10 000
hours of practicing the instrument
it's more about how you actually
absorb all that information right um
english when you learn your first
language you didn't learn the letters
first right you didn't learn grammar
first
yeah you only heard what adults were
saying and you were copying
oh like my mom said hi and he said hi so
that must be a greeting right
if you teach a kid music that way like i
do a lick he does a lick
oh that must mean communicating and
he'll learn that that's communicating
instead of knowing
oh that's a doremi that's a faso
whatever whatever right
um and that's what i'm saying you have
to teach kids
music as a language not music as a
curriculum right
and that's the biggest pitfall of why i
hated piano for example at eight years
old right because they taught me
everything
as grammar or vocabulary here are your
exercises
here's your scales here's your whatever
whatever that's the
fastest way to turn somebody like off
from yeah cause i learned piano i don't
remember [ __ ] yeah exactly but if you
were taught
as a language then you would still be
jamming and like
playing with people just by ear you know
because you speak music as a language
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
see that's like one of my biggest
regrets too because i like one of my
favorite
uh specifically when it came to like
vocally who i really liked was brian
midnight yeah but i liked him so much
because i love his live performances
that [ __ ] is so good yeah you
know what i mean he splits
he speaks a music language fluently yeah
he's like proficient
what the [ __ ] because i've seen him in
live concert like three times already
right i'm literally the youngest person
there
because everybody's like 40 50 years old
and they're all black women it's just me
it's just me there you know just [ __ ]
no i know more music than any of these
[ __ ] i'm like
the [ __ ] out my way [ __ ] you know and
so but when i see him when he
plays his instrument it's like a
language it's like he's just talking
he's just talking
right some somebody will play some [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden he just starts
playing along with i'm like how the [ __ ]
did that happen
yeah you know and that's the same thing
about improv right improv is a skill
that you practice right if you improv a
lot
then you're good at it music is the same
if you improvise a lot then you become
good at improvising
exactly the same like english and music
can be compared with the same analogies
and uh same similes and stuff like that
oh that's crazy so if you were to teach
somebody how to play the guitar how
would you start it then i'm
you know so of course you need uh like
the basic muscles
like uh make sure their fingers don't
bleed out in the first week or something
like make sure
my fingers are so soft right now yeah so
give them some muscle memory first of
course and
step two is just listening to a [ __ ] ton
of music
just give them every single genre
possible have them absorb what other
musicians they're doing and make them
understand the sounds first right
before they can play uh
like they know the sound first they can
sing
and then they learn on the instrument
right they learn the context or
when you use that and why are we using
it is not as important it's more as
when should i re reply with this phrase
you get what i mean because it's not
about understanding why understanding is
understanding right it's more about when
to use the word understanding
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i see what
you're saying um so i would just sit the
kid down
ask a couple friends to come jam and
just like have him like
try to understand what we're doing right
especially if he's a very young kid
like let's say two to five years old
right all we're doing during those three
years
i won't explain anything just have him
sit with a guitar
watch us play like just watch us jam and
just like
chilling as musicians like communicating
with improvisation and stuff like that
and eventually almost a hundred percent
sure
he'll pick up most of it and then he'll
start doing it at the same level as
the professionals when he's five years
old that's crazy like i'm i'm almost a
hundred percent sure
because if you compare it to a language
like english if you put a five years
uh a three-year-old here and he just
listens to a podcast
like for two years you bet he's gonna
speak the english fluently right it's
like that dude from um that one korean
band he learned how to speak english
through watching friends yeah exactly
yeah just by osmosis right just like
absorbing it
and let's put a more uh practical
example right
why do you see some kids at three years
old speaking like an adult
it's because their parents didn't treat
them as little kids uh
most parents go like uh how are you like
they just go like the little cutie talk
whatever
but the only thing you're doing with
doing cutesy talk to your kid
is that they're gonna start speaking
cutesily right they're gonna speak like
a baby
but the kids are three years old that
speak fluently their language
is because their parents they talk to
them like an adult since they were born
yeah yeah uh hey tom like
do you want to eat and then the kid will
go like yes i want to eat because
they've been hearing how the pranks
communicate
for as long as he's being born that's
crazy yeah
yeah man like i've i've i i don't know
if it makes sense no that
that doesn't make sense that does make
sense man it's just
you know i mean you definitely do have
an ability and a skill that a lot of
people don't have yeah you know it's
it's it's talent you know there's talent
and obviously like hard work is there
too
and a little bit of luck and a little
bit of grace everything kind of comes
together definitely you know
and i guess like for you you know before
we sign off like what what's like some
advice that you can give to somebody who
wants to go into the same route because
i also have other fans who
you know like you watched my videos yeah
they never turned out as well as you did
yeah you know
um this is like from my perspective of
things sometimes
people their confidence perceives their
skill
and that's that's that's the stuff that
i get scared about for a lot of kids
right they go
oh i i've seen you know reuben do it so
i can do it and they go out and they
they kind of i think the difference
between you and them is that
you did the due diligence first and then
the the idea of becoming famous
and you know being known for your stuff
comes after because
the due diligence was done first yeah
right so i guess like for you
if somebody says that hey i want to be a
reuben what would you suggest that they
do
they want to be a reuben like in terms
of like music and where their career
wants to go because there are already
people like that now
yeah you know so first of all figure out
financial stability right your career
needs to make sense before you actually
pursue it right
you cannot uh be worried about paying
rent next month and do music it's just
any job whatsoever
you cannot be worried about paying rent
so make sure everything you're doing is
making sense financially first
because that's gonna take a big stress
off of it just from the get go right
like
you can focus on your art when you don't
have to focus about where you're gonna
sleep next month right yeah yeah uh make
sure all the numbers make sense right
okay
um why i need 10 000 followers it's
because 10 000 followers will give me
um 40 000 streams in this month if i
release a song and those 40 000 streams
equals x amount of money and i can pay
rent and once you can pay rent
focus on everything else everything else
that you love right like whether it's
due diligence
playing your instrument or whether
you're trying to network with people and
due diligence can be explained in many
ways i feel like i haven't done enough
i've just been like i just said like a
little bit of luck a little bit of grace
but always know that success is when
opportunity
meets preparation like without the both
things you don't get success right
you need to be prepared at all times to
just do your skill right like at any
moment if somebody asks you
show me your skill you need to be ready
if you're not ready then you miss your
opportunity
and you don't get that uh like that door
that they
just offered you right and you just lost
your chance completely i was lucky
enough that
i tried my best to always be prepared no
matter what situation i was put in
and when the opportunity actually came i
just answered to the door and just
make sure i gave a good impression and
that put me in places that
other people that were not prepared
didn't get a chance to be at
right and last but not least something
that gets overseeing a lot in the music
industry is
how you portray yourself you know a lot
of people are into the flex culture or
just like being rude in general
especially with musicians musicians can
get very rude and stuff but i feel like
for me
being more on the quiet side and like
um i caught fake humble because at the
end of the day i'm a narcissist
yeah but like not showing off as
like oh yeah i did this i did that like
yesterday i made ten thousand dollars
and blah blah blah blah right
not showing that type of personality
actually attracts more people to like
actually finally
find out what i do right and by starting
conversation getting people interested
in who i am
like oh how can he be at this level and
still be
nice right that will make people come to
you and ask you and when they ask you
that's a more real connection than
actively networking right yeah
and i don't know it's it's a bunch of
things that have to come together but
preparation meets opportunity
and just be a nice person yeah i mean
for sure there's this idea of
like i told the story too where i
remember when i was in san diego there
was a kid
who he kind of stood up and then he had
this whole
i mean it was it was it was a
conversation about
like how asian parents don't support
what you want to do right and
you know we hear this a lot um and i've
i understand
and i and i understand both sides
because as i get older i start to
empathize more
specifically with our parents you know
what they have to go through and kind of
what they want to see us do they don't
want to see a struggle
and you kind of already brought that to
where you think about okay well i have
to make sure i'm financially stable so i
don't have to struggle with my art which
is very sound and i don't think a lot of
people say that
you know people think that oh i'm going
to be the starving artist trust me when
you're the starting artist it's hard
you're starving you're literally
starving you know
it [ __ ] sucks it's hard it's hard to
be creative you know some people can
really work through that
but you know it's like that idea of when
people talk about
um generational wealth in this country a
lot of that generational wealth happens
because
there was a generation before them that
set them up for success
so that's what you're doing for yourself
when you kind of set yourself up
financially so you could work on your
art yes if i were to make a simple
comparison but
there was a kid in san diego when i was
doing this show where he was like oh
i hate the fact that my parents won't
let me do what i want i actually don't
even want to be in college right now and
i was like okay cool so what do you want
to do
like i want to be a musician i was like
all right so what do you do he's like he
goes oh i sing and i play guitar like
cool man well guess what there's like
400 500 people here
i have a guitar right now you could
perform something for us and he goes ah
i don't want to i was like you're full
of [ __ ]
you know you don't have the skill or the
confidence to come up here and perform
yeah it's like that's [ __ ] you know
and that was his opportunity and
he did he wasn't prepared i guess and
that could have been his first
500 followers that could have
kick-started his career you know
yeah a lot of people are full of [ __ ]
yeah they they they think
it's so easy for somebody to sit down
and say that oh you're you're so lucky
you did all this other stuff but it's
like
if you were given the same opportunity
you wouldn't have been able to
capitalize on it and that's the biggest
difference yeah
you know i think a lot of people like to
they like to be the backseat driver they
love to give instructions to people
but when you put them at the wheel they
don't know what the [ __ ] you do and it's
hard in this generation it's easy on
twitter for people to go ahead and [ __ ]
on somebody
to have opinions about stuff but when it
comes to what they have to do
they're silent yeah like that's why i
said too i put it out recently that i
was like most people
when they send me stuff that they're
going to [ __ ] me up i'm a [ __ ]
you will never say it to my face 99.9 of
people will not say that to my face
because it's you have an avatar where
there's no face to it
yeah it's easy for you to dm somebody
because you're probably in your room in
your basement and nobody gives a [ __ ]
about you
and you're hoping that when i read that
it ruins my day yeah but it doesn't ruin
my day
you know it used to when i was younger
now it's just like entertainment it's
like oh [ __ ] like i'm really [ __ ] with
this person so bad
i'm so mad you know you know my friends
know too they always see me giggling
like what are you giggling about and i
show them the message
like doesn't that make you mad it's like
no it's just it's just funny that
they're expecting a certain reaction out
of me and it
makes me laugh that their day is ruined
because of something like that
yeah yo what the [ __ ] like are you so
mad bro like yeah it's the weirdest
thing
you know you know yeah so opportunity
and that
idea of success is it's very congruent
it kind of comes together and yes like
luck makes a little bit of course
there's always a little bit of luck
you know but that's not the whole
picture that's not the whole picture and
if you really really crave for it you'll
find a way to
find that opportunity like it's not like
you have to wait for it to fall from
heaven like
if you really crave for it your
preparation will seek that opportunity
and you will find it yeah i love that
too and i had talked about this on this
podcast and there's still people who
don't understand it they go
well you're saying you're not lucky at
all listen here you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
i keep telling you it's not i'm not
saying that luck has nothing to do with
it
it's a part of the bigger picture yeah
yeah everybody has these lucky
opportunities about who capitalizes on
it yeah
who made the smarter moves it's just
it's just so more complicated than just
to say that somebody's lucky and here's
a very
uh recent example right somebody told me
they really want
music placements right they want their
music to do like sync licensing and
getting plays on shows like that right
they're like but i'm not getting the
opportunities i'm like yo literally go
to netflix right now
go to the credits whatever show you like
look for the music supervisor
stalk the crap out of that and it may
happen you know like you never know just
find them on linkedin or something email
them
and tell them hey what music do you need
i got a catalog
it's as simple as that you finding the
opportunity you know like
and it may not happen that way but i've
heard so many people that actually
did do it that way right just like uh
find the people that will make your
career happen
stalk the crap out of them email them
reach out and
you might be surprised at the outcome of
it yeah you never know you never know
the last podcast i talked about wanting
to talk to this dude china mac yeah i
dm'd you know that's what i did and
he was here right yeah yeah then it's as
simple as just
having the boss to reach out if you
really crave it
you'll find a way to achieve it yeah 100
well guys uh that wraps up this podcast
i hope you guys enjoyed that um before
this podcast ends though
uh i would love for you to play some
music and i want to kind of put it
throughout podcast so people kind of get
a feel of who you are
but uh where can they find you man uh
you can find me everywhere at
reuben one r-u-b-e-n-w-a-n spotify
instagram
youtube whatever everything is reuben
won perfect so you guys can go ahead and
support and check him out he's actually
one of my favorite
like musicians out there right now
specifically the way he creates content
and always support people that you
really
really [ __ ] with and enjoy just because
you know about them doesn't mean that
everybody else will
so uh remember genius brains every
thursdays and sundays and we'll see you
all next time take care peace bye